S
HIM.
THAT'SNG
>> THIS IS HUGELHE
APPRECIATET.A?
>>> MAGGIEN S.
ED TRUMPERDO
VIEWING THIS?
S BEENY,
VERY FRUSTRATED AND CONCERNEINVR
I THIN'SEEA COUPLE OF TIMES SI
RETURNED TO PALM BEACH.
HAVE BEEN LOTS OF MEETINGSTED T.
KNP HAA SPECIFIC
PL HE RELIES IN WHICHE CLAIMS E
HUNT AND POLITICAL ANDS BEEN
DOING  YEARS.ID IT A T IN THEHI
GOING THERE OF THAT IN E  DAYS
ANOUTHIS.
HOULD HIS
INTIES OR
NTN FOR HIM EVEN IN
2024? I THINK GOING TO
CRSE LIKELIHOOD THAT AT
MINIMUM, BRIANNA'S GOING T GOINU
PEOPLE AROUND THAT HN.
IN RELATION TO THE VANCEN.ECOND
NG --  CAN'T BA  I'M
CODEA NEW POLLG I'R  SAYING SO E
HAT SEEN THE DATA.
OINGY.
HE'S GOING TO SAESOPLEG AFTER M
HILL MANY THE
PO
AGAIN, HE'NING,
RIGHT?
X ARS, WHEN YOU'RE ALWAYS G,OUGT
YOU'REOIO HEAR HIM HARCA
>> HOW DOES THIS AFFECT THE
THE ? IA REALLY GOOD QUESTION,
ONE OF THES THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS FRURA  O
D OTHER
INVESTIGATIONS HOVERING OVER
KEPEATEDLY AND
SAID SINCE, S BUSINESSOOT WHEN .
THINUNHELPFUL TO HIM.
HIS SONS HADE ILE HE WASSINOW H.
INTHTIRE T FAM
CONCERNEDINVESTATHAT IT COULD
MEAN, WHICH IS NOT TO SAY, BY
LEGALLY FOR HI, SE OF WHATSTIGAE
S OF CONCERN
BETHEY'RE ALN  EXERCISE.
WITH KER O, AND I KNOW YOU'VE
WTICH TO TO N BACK
HOUSE SEATS IN THEIDTERMS.
E BEEN
COOKINUP? SO, BRIANH
NDSEY GRAHAM HAVE
O GET TRUMP TO ON METHING ,
SOMETHING ALONG THNE
CONTRAITH AMERICA,NGICDI0sSOMET.
Y WANT TO DO, PART OF
THAT, GETRTOP
ION.
HE KEEPS TALKING ABOUT THEAIMS.
TH IETO
AST THAT BECAUSE I THE REPUBLICS
GRME MIXED  QUESTI.
WE'LL SE ONE WORKS.
TRUMEMNA IT'FOR HIS PARTY.ANKSIS
IN>>> JOINING ME, ER
PROFESSOR RECOY I
QUOTE TWA
POST" SAYING THE FACT OFS
SPECIAL GRAND JURY TELLS
WHY?PROSECUTION HA.
>>S D
STANDARD OF PR -
JOKE ABOUT
OBLIGATION, ETHICAL OBLIGATION
TO MAKE SURE DOING JUST
SOE ECS
THEMSELVES, I'M INFERRING, MUS
HAVE A SENSEHEAINST WHO, I'T
>> ANE IS KEY. W OUT, IT'SAR
AGKEHIS KINDF
EMY
LAWY ME  W
AY.
SO IT COULD BE A CASE AGAINST
THE ORZA
T TOTALLY COULD.
THWANT TINOUT,
DIFFERENT FROM THE FERAL.
ONE WAY, CAN'T
ARSAY EVIDENCE.
TO PRESENT ISAME QUALITY
THAT MVE TO PRESENT AT TRIAL.
THAT'STHAT I  CASE REOU BE PRSUE
THINK THE OFFICE ITSELF IS
FALY CONVINCEDT HACASE.
, RIGHT, WE N'
IT COULD BE AGNSOTHER INDIVIDUA
IN ORGANIZATION.
WE REALLY DON'T KNOWON'T AUSE OC
BEFORE THE GRAND JURY.S THAT TEU
IF HE TESTIFIEFORE G
JURY.  RIGHT.
UN H.
TRANSANAS PRETTY
BIG.
IT MEANS YOU CAN'T PROSECUTE TH
SECRET, BUT IF THAT COMESOME W,I